the biggest explosions in the universe
come from some of the smallest stars
they illuminate the universe and the
processes that have occurred since the
dawn of time itself and today we're
going to explore the physics of these
stars so-called supernovae how they came
to be the deaths of stars and the birth
of the universe
[Music]
inside every star is a battle between
gravity tending to compress it and the
repulsive force of photons escaping
outward these photons come from nuclear
fusion
this process produces heat and the star
is in balance this balance can last for
billions of years some stars don't have
a thermonuclear core anymore they've
gotten quite old and this type of stars
called it white dwarf some of the white
dwarfs are hypothesized to have within
them pure carbon which could be in the
form of a diamond shown here and this
entire star weighing as much as
140 percent of the mass of our sun
this white dwarf can be the same size as
the earth which is a million times
smaller than the sun
so a white dwarf is a dead star it's no
longer undergoing photonic production
because it's no longer producing fusion
at its core they're held up by the
pressure the mutual repulsion of
electrons in a degenerate quantum state
as you add in more mass they get smaller
this is a particular and peculiar state
of matter called highly degenerate
matter
now supernovae are going to play in our
role as they have throughout the history
of cosmology illuminating processes that
are extremely violent supernova had been
observed throughout our history as a
species perhaps from thousands of years
ago right up until the 1980s when i was
a wee lad getting ready to go to college
this supernova cult supernova 1987a went
off
in the large magellanic cloud which is a
satellite galaxy of the milky way and
was observed by astronomers and some
people have wondered what would happen
if a supernova went off much closer to
us than the large maginot cloud which is
hundreds of thousands of light years
away from the earth well it could be
really quite disastrous for life on
earth a type 1a supernova is incredibly
important for our understanding of the
luminosity distance to distant objects
which is how cosmologists determine that
the universe is not only
expanding but the rate of expansion is
increasing i.e accelerating revealing in
turn the presence of dark energy a type
1a supernova is a bomb in space it's the
explosion of a white dwarf in a binary
system the binary system could be
another type of star say depicted here a
sun like star which has its matter
sucked by these vampires called white
dwarfs white dwarves have incredible
tidal gravitational forces you can also
have a white dwarf merging with another
white dwarf and as this occurs the
eventual time will come
when the white dwarf has a mass greater
than the chandrasekhar mass limit of 1.4
times the mass of the sun
at such a mass the system goes supernova
and explodes now this type of process
which is incredibly luminous is to be
distinguished from what's called a type
2 supernova a type 2 supernova is really
thought of as another type of bomb but a
gravitational bomb
it's a bomb that results when the outer
layers of a star collapse onto its core
this occurs when a star ceases being
able to provide that pressure
to counteract the gravitational in-fall
of its matter
so these processes are very simple even
though they involve
things like nuclear fusion and nuclear
explosion which are very complicated
processes but the actual physics is a
mechanical balance between pressure
outwardly and gravitational forces
attracting matter towards itself
once the pressure support disappears the
whole sham is up and the star's outer
layers collapse down fall in and
eventually have a shock wave that
rebounds now this rebounding can produce
the heavy elements that were last being
produced at the core of a star and in
fact many of these were discovered right
here by my colleagues at uc san diego
jeff and margaret burbidge who in 1957
published an apocal paper with fred
hoyle and willie fowler this was called
production of elements and stars or
synthesis of elements in stars known by
its initials
bbfh one of the most famous papers not
only in astrophysics history but really
in all of physics but paved the way for
understanding of how these stars produce
the metals and elements that we're made
up of in fact the iron at the core of a
type 2 supernova that central figure
shown here produces the source of the
iron that's in our blood and the
hemoglobin molecule without it we
wouldn't be here but that iron came from
the explosion of a type 2 supernova in
our region of the galaxy some 5 billion
or more years ago now astronomers don't
make use purely of these explosive
phenomena by themselves just the
explosion itself they also want to look
at the chemical fingerprint the spectrum
of these stars so astronomers break
these two supernova types down into two
main categories type one type two but
these explosions are incredibly
important and so astronomers classify
them in major subsets type one supernova
broken down into type 1a and type 1b
type 1 a is distinguished as we just
described as the thermonuclear
detonation of a dwarf star in a binary
system type 1b is the same as the
previous supernova type 2 that i just
described gravity bomb except in this
case the stars that have lost their
outer layers via the the puffing out of
what are called stellar winds and this
is very telltale for my extremely clever
astronomy colleagues they can rapidly
distinguish between a type 1 type 1a
type 1b supernova and really focus on
the ones that they want to use for the
particular application when it comes to
understanding the expansion of the
universe and how that's accelerating
that process relies on type 1 a
supernova not the type 2 supernova and
not the type 1b supernode and what we
want to do for all of these is really
characterize the luminosity of the
object and related to its distance it's
hard to measure the distance to an
astronomical object because we don't
have a depth perception in cosmology
we're really good at seeing left and
right up and down measuring the position
to micro arc second precision but it's
very hard without a model that relates
the redshift which is easy to measure
and the distance which is hard to
measure we want to come up with a
relationship between those two that
depends on the composition of the
universe what is contained in the
universe what how much matter there is
in ordinary matter like protons and
neutrons
croutons and also how much non-ordinary
matter dark matter there is and then how
much dark energy there is so there are
many types of 1a supernova that can
exist they're very bright you can see
them very far out in the distant
universe they explode at a very well
calibrated amount of mass which via the
most famous equation in all of physics e
equals mc squared once you know the mass
is well established you can convert
exactly to the amount of energy produced
and then calculate how much of that's in
the form of light and use that to
calculate how much light is observed and
how much you would observe given
different amounts of dark matter dark
energy in the universe this is what
cosmologists do this then allows us
using the simple inverse square law to
measure very accurately for a known
amount of luminosity the distance to
these objects let's take a quick detour
astronomers for all their brilliance
have used a very obtuse way of measuring
brightness or luminosity called the
magnitude going back to the ancient
greek times there are two types of
magnitude the magnitude related to how
much light is being produced by an
object and the amount of light that we
on earth or in the space telescope are
observing the intrinsic luminosity which
is being produced by the object is going
to be given a magnitude symbol capital m
and then what we observe is lowercase m
so it's confusing because it's the same
sounding word m and m and
it's not the wrapper we can construct a
difference between what we observe and
what was produced lowercase m minus
uppercase m we call that quantity mu
that depends on the luminosity distance
which is hard to measure and we relate
mu
to the parameters of the expansion of
the universe the hubble expansion
constant h naught
and the so-called deceleration parameter
q sub naught these were thought to be
the only two parameters of interest in
the early universe called by alan
sandage cosmology was the search for two
numbers the expansion of the universe
via its hubble constant and the
deceleration was thought that the
universe would decelerate because
there's matter and so matter only
attracts gravitationally why would you
expect there to be anything other than
deceleration for a universe after all
which we know contains mass but
astronomers didn't find that
they found that q was negative
what's called negative deceleration
and so astronomers use these different
colored filter bands to define different
wavelength regimes for different
purposes and then they ask well how much
redshift is there for these different
wavelength bands of a given type 1a
supernova and they've been doing this
literally for decades
and the culmination of this
was the awarding of the nobel prize to
two past guests on the into the
impossible podcast we had adam reece
we've had brian schmidt on the podcast
have yet to get saul promoter on we need
saul
he won't do it if you are listening out
there saul you know i've been sending
you emails you could ask him hey i could
ask him please do come on
in some way they are related to a friend
of ours uh bob kirschner who will also
hopefully someday be on the podcast it's
all good man is now taking over
leadership role of the 30 meter
telescope so exciting so the observation
of these stars led to a convergence that
the universe had a substantial amount of
energy density in the form of a vacuum
or cosmological constant heretofore
unexpected that was the only way to
explain
the not only expanding universe but the
rate of change and increase in the
expansion rate of the universe this was
astounding and now decades after the
initial discovery papers the data have
even gotten stronger and more conclusive
we have the so-called benchmark model
that depicts a universe
that at very early times was dominated
by heat by the energy of photons that
would later become the cmb
and slowly thereafter
about 200 000 years after the big bang
became dominated by matter
and then only a few billion years ago so
many maybe 10 billion years after the
big bang did dark energy take over and
become the dominant force of expansion
in the universe so photons in matter
actually cause the universe to
decelerate to get smaller and smaller
hubble constants over time and dark
energy does the opposite causes the
hubble constant to increase so therefore
looking at different redshifts you will
expect to see different phenomena it's
unequivocal these data points as they
say keep getting stronger and stronger
you can read about the discovery of this
in a wonderful book by bob kershner
called the extravagant universe and
going through the different phenomena
that we could expect to see the universe
could have been
either expanding forever it could be
coasting it could have never started to
expand in the very beginning all these
phenomena were ruled out by these
observations in combinations with
measurements of the omega matter
component as shown here
the omega matter component is very
accurately traced by phenomena like the
cosmic microwave background and isotropy
which will be spoken about in upcoming
videos and it can be measured by
so-called baryon acoustic oscillation
observations both of which trace the
processes of ordinary matter which we
call baryonic matter and non-ordinary
matter which we call dark matter really
a stand-in a placeholder for unknown
physics that we don't understand so
here's what a supernova looks like at
different times the supernova will peak
at a certain time and then the
brightness will decay over time so this
is showing the light curve decay this is
coming from bob kirschner these
observations at different time scales
will be tracing out a very
characteristic curve that astronomers
like bob and his colleagues have
characterized very well over the decades
so you can actually see the supernova
can be actually brighter than the galaxy
that's hosting it which is quite amazing
and these characteristic curves are
traced out for all sorts of supernova
and all sorts of wavelength regimes
shown here is different colors
at the same time scale and you see
different phenomena that take place
and it's actually possible to
distinguish between the supernovas
behavior in its visible or optical light
wavelength bands versus the infrared
bands shown here and actually looks
different in the infrared versus the
optical in the optical it clearly has
just one hump one peak and in the
infrared it has multiple humps or
multiple peaks giving you multiple bites
at the cosmic apple understanding how
the universe has been expanding since
the supernova have blown up what do we
do with supernova cosmology we start by
measuring the magnitude
brightness of a given exploding star
once we know it's a type 1a we measure
the light curves as a function of time
and as many wavelengths as we can that's
a technical challenge but that's that's
really that's technical talk that
doesn't really astronomers are really
good at solving those technical
challenges they measure the redshift
from the spectrum you take the inferred
distance modulus which is the magnitude
that you observe lowercase m minus the
intrinsic magnitude uppercase m which
comes from a model to construct that and
compare that for as many different type
1a supernova as you can measure and you
make a so-called hobble diagram
plotting the distance modulus mu as a
function of redshift and then you
compare those to a theoretical model
which will predict the distance modulus
at a given redshift for a given
cosmological combination you put in
different ingredients different amounts
of dark matter ordinary matter dark
energy and you mix it together and you
ask how does that affect the distance
modulus as a function of redshift you
plot all those you do a likelihood
analysis and this is what astronomers
did it sounds easy now it was really
hard back then they got it right the
first time and they won of course the
ultimate prize
and i think it's quite striking that
astronomers continue to use this and
these tools are now being used to settle
another perhaps cosmic mystery or
perhaps even raise the tension to higher
and higher levels why do the
cosmic measurements from cmb experiments
like the kind i just described why they
differ so much from the late time
universe measurements
after all the universe was much more
simple in the distant past in the early
universe than it is when supernovas
start to form and galaxies start to
cluster
they should get the same answer but they
don't that's called the hubble tension
we've discussed one possible mechanism
which relies on magnetic fields because
of this we have a very very significant
opportunity to get even more information
about from the late universe
observations of supernova and cepheid
variables compare that to early
measurements perhaps with upcoming
instruments like the simon's observatory
and we will continue to discuss the
hubble tension and possible solutions to
it and possible other contributors to
this cosmic energy pie chart shown here
in terms of different candidates for the
amount of dark energy and dark matter
that we know to exist
if you like this video please check out
this video over here where i explain the
possible solutions to the hubble tension
using magnetic fields don't forget to
subscribe